it was supposed to be a weekend of
remembrance and relaxation Filipinos
traditionally flocked to cemeteries this
time of year to remember deceased
friends and families but this Cemetery
the largest in Manila was closed as the
threat of tropical storm gnologue
flower vendors were willing to risk it
but there was no business
there was a pandemic right we really
wanted to see how many people would have
come here for the first time in two
years
we're staying put because we have to
guard the flowers
bus terminals that would have been
crowded were nearly empty many of those
who did decide to travel got stuck in
ports with air and sea travel also
suspended
to boost tourism the government has
declared this long weekend a holiday a
tropical storm Nagi has hampered travel
plans in the affected areas worse rescue
operations are in full swing as entire
Villages are submerged by flood water
before the storm had even made landfall
in the Philippines parts of the country
were already experiencing heavy downpour
for days flash floods caught many in the
province of makinda Now by surprise
rescue workers scrambled to get to those
who needed help but help did not come
quickly enough for one Village kushong
instantly became a site of past casualty
and the aftermath was nothing short of
catastrophic Forum chief minister ahud
at an emergency meeting on Saturday
president Ferdinand Marcos wondered how
such a tragedy could have happened
what caused the flooding why weren't
they evacuated what happened and why so
many deaths
government officials hope the death toll
won't increase significantly but the
storm size covered nearly the entire
country
and as it continued to sweep through the
main island of Luzon through the Sunday
it's difficult to say how much more
Devastation it will leave in its wake
me below Al Jazeera Manila